الاتحاد الاوروبي بشده قرار السلطات
الاسرائيليه السماحه للمستوطنين لاقامه
وجود دائم في مستوطنه حومش بالضفه الغربيه
المحتله وحتى الاتحاد الحكومه الاسرائيليه
على التراجع عن هذا القرار وقراراتها التي
اتخذها اتخذها الاسبوع الماضي للدفع قدما
لبناء اكثر من 600 وحده استيطانيه في
المستوطنات القائمه والجديده في الضفه
الغربيه هذا وجدد الاتحاد الاوروبي تاكيده
على ان المستوطنات غير قانونيه بموجب
القانون الدولي وتقوض قابليه حل الدولتين
للحياه واضاف ان مثل هذه الاجراءات
تتعارضوا مع جهود المبذوله لتهدئه
التوترات على الارض
معنى الالم رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البديري كيف استقبلت هذه الاداره
جيفارا من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي لاقامه
هذه المستوطنات من جديد او السماح
للمستوطنين بالعوده اليها
على المستوى الرسمي باهتمام مبالغ ايمان
قبلت هذه
الادانه ولكن بالطبع تضاف الى ادانات
سابقه ان لم يتم تحويل الاقوال الى افعال
وفق عدد من المسؤولين الفلسطينيين البيان
تحديدا ايمان جاء بعد جوله قام بها وفدا
رفيع يمثل الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي هنا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه الى قريتي برقه
وسباستيا وقريه برقه هي المقامه عليها
مستوطنات حومش هذه المستوطنه التي تم
اخلائها عام 2005 عند عمليه الانسحاب
بانقطاع غزه واربع مستوطنات في الضفه
الغربيه في اذار الماضي وبعد ضغط من
اليمين واليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل في
اذار الماضي قرر الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فك
الارتباط حسب ما وصفه واعاده المستوطنين
الى هذه المستوطنات الاربعه ولكن الب
المستوطنه حومش حومش تقطع الطريق في شمال
الضفاء الغربيه خاصه بين محافظات نابلس
جنين وطولكرم ورغم مرور 18 عاما على هذا
الاخلاء لم يتمكن الاهالي من البناء في
هذه المناطق التي تم مصادرتها لانه حتى
وان اخليت هذه المستوطنه الا ان الاراضي
المحيطه بها بقيت تحت تصنيف الوجود
العسكري
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي اليوم الوفد الاوروبي
شاهد على الارض وسمع من الاهالي كميه
الغضب الفلسطيني نتيجه هذا القرار
الاسرائيلي استمرار 18 عاما من الاجراءات
العسكريه وعنف المستوطنين تحديدا وهو ما
اثار حفيظه الاتحاد الاوروبي وعليه بالطبع
صدر هذا البيان عقب الزياره الذي كان شديد
اللهجه تحدث فيه عن الاستيطان نتحدث عن
750 الف مستوطن في اكثر من 182 مستوطنه
وبالتالي الفلسطينيون بانتظار الافعال
شكرا لك جيفارا المديري كنت معنا من رام
الله